you are looking at video from as it says
there moments ago Tamar just getting out
of the car just back from the hospital
Tamar Braxton returned to the Dancing
with the Stars ballroom just in time to
avoid disqualification the 38 year old
entertainer was admitted to the hospital
earlier in the day after battling
pneumonia and exhaustion was danced at
the wheel Thursday I was in Vegas all
righty I came back to LA at a concert
with Kim Saturday I got on the plane and
Sunday I'm back here put my camera
Blanca
it's just nuts that she missed her first
performance leaving the judges to score
her based off her dress rehearsal
performance earning a 22 out of 30
determined to continue competing Tamar
made it back just moments before her
second performance joining Nick and
Sharna for a group dance tributing the
Cirque de Soleil show love hey don't
make it bad take
remember to let her into your heart then
you can start to making
the group earned a 27 out of 30 and both
couples survived elimination